yes there is one leftist icon who does
not seem so thrilled
with blm and the blm leaders
and the anti-americanism that they
foment who would that
icon be i think i've already given it
away
it would be the notorious rbg
justice ginsburg how do you feel about
san francisco
49ers player colin kaepernick and other
nfl players
who have basically
refused to stand for the national anthem
and what do i think i think is really
dumb of them
would i arrest them for doing it no i
think it's
dumb and disrespectful
uh the same i would have the same answer
if you asked me about
flag burning i said i think it's a
terrible thing to do
but i wouldn't lock a person up for
doing it
i would point out how
ridiculous it seems to me to do such a
such an act i got to tell you the more i
hear about this rbg lady the more i like
her
the more reasonable she sounds gosh i
totally agree
burning the flag is a horrible terrible
thing to do
and disrespecting the flag in the way
that colin kaepernick and blm have done
are very stupid very disrespectful
how many left-wingers presently invoking
the sainted rpg
would be willing to acknowledge all of
that probably very few
but the reason for that is that rbg is
giving
a liberal political view of flag burning
and
the kneeling at the flag and
disrespecting the anthem
that's a liberal political view namely i
don't like it but i wouldn't arrest you
for it it's not that big a deal but you
still you shouldn't do it
the difference is that blm is not merely
political but it is taken on
the tone and the form of a religious
liturgy
very clearly the kneeling the kneeling
is a religious action
the the blm supporters are genuflecting
but it's an inverse religious liturgy so
they're not genuflecting on their knee
to show respect they're genuflecting to
show disrespect for the flag because
america is a hateful place and the cops
are racist and whatever
other nonsense they want to spew so it's
a sort of
inverse religious liturgy rather than
being edifying in community obviously
it's divisive and tears the country down
rather than being salvific it's
destructive
but that is the religious liturgies why
you can't argue with them
it's why they have all these kind of
cockamamie theories about human nature
like white people bad or black people
good or
that there's this superstructure of
oppression in the world that they
call white supremacy the
the actual superstructure of oppression
in the world is satan
this fallen world the prince of darkness
principalities and powers
spiritual wickedness in high places
that's the actual spiritual
oppression that we have but because the
left is
vaguely materialistic vaguely
anti-christian or anti-religious
sometimes explicitly so that they can't
make sense of that so it has to be
physical
it can't be a spiritual darkness it has
to be a a
physical problem namely skin color or
sex right i mean we're focusing on the
racial aspects but
could be sex men bad women good straight
people
bad uh non-straight people good you know
lgbt lmnop
or in the blm what we believe section
when they say we're here to
disrupt the western prescribed nuclear
family
they want to destroy the nuclear family
for that reason because all of the
structures of society are oppressive
karl marx famously called for the
ruthless criticism of all that exists
and his acolytes in the cultural spheres
then
took up that crusade and that's what
we're seeing
not merely political certainly also
religious
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]